- Hi, everyone.
It gives me great
pleasure to invite you all
to our continuing monthly
Inference Colloquium Series.
These talks, followed by
discussion sessions the next day,
are part of our larger
intellectual project
on trying to understand
the nature of causation,
correlation, and inference
across disciplines.
Our series, as many of you may know,
has comprised talks by eminent scholars
whose domains of expertise span physics,
philosophy of science, mathematics,
and including, in the coming months,
talks by a biologist, an
organizational behavior expert,
and a computer scientist.
The goals of our project
are to really understand
how we infer from models,
the power and the limits of
models as inferential engines.
And I'm really excited
that today's speaker
is the philosopher of science whose work
is centered on physics, Dr. Elise Crull,
whose talk is titled,
"No Cause for Concern:
"Indefinite Causal Ordering
"as a Tool for
Understanding Entanglement."
And I'm delighted that our
conversant with Dr. Crull,
tomorrow's discussion session,
is the eminent philosopher of science,
Professor Yemima Ben-Menachem
from the Department of Philosophy,
the Hebrew University of Jerusalem.
We are absolutely delighted to
have both of them participate
in the sequence of events.
But before we start today's presentation
and I introduced Dr. Crull,
I would like to recognize our benefactors,
Mr. And Mrs. Richard and Barbara Franke,
whose generosity in setting up
this unique interdisciplinary program,
and many other activities at Yale,
have greatly enriched the campus
and the university's mission.
Also, I need to remind those of you
who are assembled here today
that we are recording this event
and that all participants must
therefore mute their videos.
And as per usual, please
feel free to submit questions
through the chat feature
for the Q and A session
at the end of the talk.
Now, to introduce professor Elise Crull,
who is a faculty member at
the Department of Philosophy
in the City University of New York.
After studying physics and
astronomy at Calvin University,
a very robust and good intellectual
background, I might add.
I'm joking, of course,
I say this as an astrophysicist myself.
That Professor Crull took the plunge
into interdisciplinary waters,
earning both an MA and a PhD
in the history and philosophy of science
from the University of Notre Dame.
Before coming to CUNY in 2014,
she held postdoctoral positions
at the University of Aberdeen
and at the Hebrew University's
Edelstein Center for History
and Philosophy of Science,
Technology and Medicine,
where she spent many blissful
hours huddled over documents
in the Einstein Archives.
Oh gosh, I'm envious.
While most of her research today concerns
historical and philosophical foundations
of quantum mechanics, Crull
is also drawn to questions
in sort of this hinterland
between contemporary metaphysics
and physics, these other really profound
and complex questions that
have been very, very hard
to even methodologically approach.
And Elise has made enormous headway
in many of these important questions.
In particular, she's interested in
the philosophical
implications of entanglement
and quantum decoherence,
how these phenomena modify
traditional views about the
structure of space time,
and what explanatory roles they might play
within various approaches
to an emerging theory
of quantum gravity.
So without further ado,
Elise, the floor is yours.
- [Elise] How does everything look?
- [Priya] Looks great.
- Fantastic.
Well, thank you for that
generous introduction, Priya,
and thank you for the
invitation, also Priya and Ty,
to be a part of this really wonderful,
very deeply and genuinely
interdisciplinary colloquium
on inference and causation.
And I also wanna say
thank you to the Frankes,
just for their center.
Such scholarship, encouraging
it among undergraduates
and graduates and faculty is just
the beating heart of the academy, I think.
So thank you for your endeavors to create
these sorts of spaces for us.
So today, I'll be speaking
about the lack of causality
or indefiniteness in causality.
Hence, no cause for concern,
I've subtitled it
"Indefinite Causal Ordering
"as a Tool for
Understanding Entanglement,"
but I'll, in fact, be saying something
a little bit broader than that,
not just about understanding entanglement,
where I'll make some provisional gestures,
but really just thinking about
indefinite causal ordering
of quantum processes carefully,
and understanding what this new physics,
how it might inform various discussions
in quantum information,
quantum computation,
quantum gravity, non-relatives
as quantum mechanics,
and of course, in philosophy of physics.
So let's dive in.
Okay.
And apologies in advance
if my cat wanders by.
He just loves entanglement.
So I would like to begin
by setting the stage,
just giving you a quick
sneak peek of one small part
of a vast philosophical
literature on causation,
and then by giving you a
sneak peek of the discussion
that's happening around
causality in physics,
just a little bit, and then I'll give you
a plan for the talk, and we'll go on.
So here is just the brief set up.
Now, Matthias Fritsch has
just, in the last, I think,
10 months, written a Stanford
Encyclopedia of Philosophy
entry on causation in physics.
And I highly recommend, and
I believe there's a link
on the website to his article.
And it's just a very clear
taxonomy of the problems
and discussions and
debates through history.
But one thing he does,
which is really nice,
is to characterize the causation
discussion in philosophy
as being groups of projects
that may have overlapping,
but a little bit separable aims.
So there are metaphysical projects,
projects that wanna think about causation
and what it implies about
the way the world really is.
And what is cause?
What does cause mean about
spatial temporal relations?
What level in the ontological hierarchy
should causal processes
exist in? and so on.
There are also sort of
descriptive projects
that want to understand what is it
that physicists are actually doing
when they invoke cause or causal processes
or causal laws in particular theories.
And then there's also the functional aim.
How does cause help us make inferences?
How does cause help us link
up different phenomena,
regimes of phenomenon?
And so on.
So that's a quick parsing
of the philosophical space.
And Yemima has written a lovely book
that came out a couple years ago called
"Causation in Science," and
she is not primarily concerned
with the metaphysical project, I believe.
But we'll let her say
more about that tomorrow.
I will be, today, thinking,
as the first way in,
about metaphysics.
And in this direction,
there are sort of three camps, right?
And here they're listed.
There are causal fundamentalists.
I know we get sort of skeeved out
by the word fundamentalist,
but here it just means
that causal laws are
a fundamental part of the universe.
So if we find some grand unifying theory,
whatever law sits in that
theory as sort of the basic law
will be a causal law.
Or it could be a thesis that says,
"There exists some
universal causal principle."
And this was historically
motivated for a lot of reasons,
because we look at the world
around us that seems that
events are causally
related to one another.
And how do we do science?
We do science by
exploring such connections
or such relations.
So these two theses come out of
a classical understanding the world.
But in recent times, there
have been these other views,
namely the causal limitivist view,
which was maybe made most
famous by John Wharton
in the last few decades.
And causal limitivism is just
the denial of fundamentalism.
They say, "Look, there is no
fundamental causal principle."
Maybe cause pops up here and
there in our descriptions,
or it's a functional tool that we use
to build our theories and
make predictions and so on,
but it isn't a part of the
actual structure of the world.
So Norton wants to go even
further than just eliminating
cause from the bottom level,
he wants to say that
cause only ever appears
in this sort of emergent fashion,
and where it appears, when
we're using that term "cause,"
it can always be reduced.
Whatever law or relationship
is being described
with that term can be reduced to a law
or a relationship that is
fundamentally non-causal.
In other words, what looks like causal
at the operational and functional level
disappears or reduce it to something
that is ultimately non causal, right?
So causal limitivists,
let's eliminate cause.
And it's a pretty strong position.
Somewhere between the last two camps
are the non-fundamentalists.
And if you're philosophers,
you've heard about
the Humean Controversy or the Humeans,
tend to be the non-fundamentalists.
And they deny both of the theses,
that there exists a
universal causal principle.
And they also wanna say that
causal laws do not exist
as part of the fundamental
gnomic structure
or law-like structure of the universe.
But they're gonna disagree
with the limitivist too,
by saying that causal
structures or causal talk
can still play robust or
genuine roles in explaining,
or maybe there are some
views where causality
does properly emerge at some
higher level of your ontology.
But it isn't at the fundamental level.
Fundamental level is just a
Humean mosaic, if you will.
So those are the three camps.
And I'll be looking at the physics
and then sort of asking
what the physics has to say,
maybe, about these three camps,
if it informs our discussion in any way.
All right, so what's the
discussion over in physics?
There are a few types of responses,
crudely categorize, once again.
Of course, causal assumptions are crucial
for classical modeling
and in classical theories,
but it's been understood
for quite some time
that quantum mechanics allows
for non-causal situations.
Whether non-causal is
equivalent to a-causal
or just indefinite
causally-ordered situations
will be a question we ask later on.
But there are a variety
of approaches, right?
There are there those theorists, usually,
who say, "Look, yes, it's
possible that there is
"a lack of causal structure
"or there's some kind of
indefinite causal ordering, ICO,
"that exists at the bottom
level in our quantum theories,
"or whatever, but nevertheless,
"what this should inspire
us to do is to develop
"causally neutral quantum formalisms.
"Or on the other hand, develop measures
"for how non-causal certain
structures are," right?
So maybe this is just a way
of saying we should divorce
our quantum formalism from the assumption
of a background space time or a background
causal apparatus of some sort.
So I believe that Hartree Fields,
causally neutral formalism
is sort of of that vein.
Another formal response would be, okay,
so at the bottom level we have
indefinite causal ordering,
but perhaps there are
formalisms we can develop
or tools we can develop
that allow us to recover
causal structure.
And that also is being done, for instance,
by Costus and Shrapnel, who developed
a causal Markovian condition
for quantum systems.
So these people are less interested
in a metaphysical question
of why we don't see cause
at the bottom level, or should
we be seeing it, or whatever
and are just saying, okay,
given that we have the possibility
of weird causal situations
from quantum mechanics,
how can we adjust the framework
or the formalism up here
so that we can go on
with our modeling tasks
or enhance our modeling tasks?
There has been an experimental response.
Some of which is to say, "Okay,
this lack of causal ordering
"can be a way for us
to increase efficiency
"in quantum computation
or information technology
"or information theory or
quantum communications," right?
And this has already been done.
And I'll discuss a paper where
indefinite causal ordering is in fact
more efficiently allowed
for us to do computation
of some specific problem,
as opposed to a
causally-ordered superposition
of a quantum surface circuit.
Okay.
There's also a theoretical
response that says,
"Well, let's look at this
lack of causal ordering
"and use it to ask those deeper questions
"about fundamental features
or fundamental properties
"of the universe from quantum theory."
So as Schrodinger said,
in his entanglement paper
for the Cambridge Society in 1935,
entanglement is not one, but
the characteristic property
that causes departure
from classical theories.
So entanglement is
quantumness, in essence.
And there are some theoretical
work or proposed experiments
that use indefinite causal
ordering to understand
or probe entanglement
in various situations.
So that's very cool.
So it might shed...
We might be able to use
indefinite causal ordering
to shed some light on these old questions
about the underlying
properties of the world
from quantum mechanics.
We might also use it in
our future theorizing,
not just to understand
quantum mechanics per se,
but maybe we can look at
the lack of causal ordering
as motivating certain efforts to quantize
general relativity or to
quantize gravity over others.
And so, I'll have more to
say about that in the future.
So, a lot of responses
from the physics, as well,
and we'll zoom in on a few
of these that will feed,
I hope, into a metaphysical-type piece.
So, plan of the talk, pretty
typical philosophy of physics
sort of talk.
I'm gonna start by looking at
some of the physics, right?
I'll ask sort of...
I'll look at three things, here.
First, I'll briefly discuss,
since this is an
interdisciplinary audience,
why would we expect
indefinite causal ordering
in quantum processes in the first place?
And once we've covered that ground,
I'll look at a particular
experimental case,
the quantum switch.
And the quantum switch is
a way of measuring degrees
of non-causal correlation among processes.
So, it's very cool.
And then I'll look at a relativistic case.
So this is an experiment, well,
a theoretical experiment
presented by Henderson, who's,
she's at, I think,
Waterloo, and co-workers.
And there, they're looking at how-
- [Priya] Elise, I have a quick question.
- [Elise] Sure.
- [Priya] Is there a reason you are using
the word process rather than event?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- And that will become
a little bit clearer
when we get into the details
of the quantum switch.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
So Henderson and her
colleagues have been looking at
quantum field theory entangling detectors
that are coupled to the field,
and using that to harvest entanglement.
And they've found some
preliminary, very interesting,
both more efficacious
ways of coupling detectors
in a non-causal superposition.
They can harvest more entanglement
with that kind of superposition
among their detectors.
And also, they raised some very
interesting questions about,
well, what does it really
mean to have the detectors,
which are physical things, presumably,
in super positions that are
physical states, presumably,
that nevertheless yield
these strange sort of
backwards-forwards superpositions.
So look at the physics first.
And then the second part will
be just sort of drawing out
some of the consequences of this physics.
And this is the part where I'm
doing totally new stuff here
with you all, now.
And so I'd love to have lots of discussion
with you all about it.
So again, I'll sort of
look at the quantum switch
and what it might imply or not imply
about causation in quantum physics.
And then I'll look at
the case of entanglement,
harvesting, and QFT, and sort of have
a think about what that might mean.
And then part three is very quick.
It's just where I'm gonna
make some talk-sized theses,
the specific talk-sized
thesis about causality
and quantum theories, what can we say,
given ICO as an active area of theoretical
and experimental research right now?
What can we conclude about
causality in quantum?
But also, maybe, in physics
more generally, maybe.
And then a general thesis,
which isn't about physics alone,
but as a back to that
question I started with
about the metaphysics of causation itself.
Has any of the physics that I go through,
has it modified or made
easier or more difficult
certain aspects or defenses
for those three main approaches
to the metaphysics of causation,
the Humean non-fundamentalist account,
the non-Humean sort of
fundamentalist account,
and then the elimitavists?
Okay, here we go.
So, the physics.
Why do we expect
indefinite causal ordering
in quantum processes in the first place?
Well, in the literature, and I think
there's some care that needs to be taken
from philosophers here, too.
because in the literature
it's very quickly said
by the physicist that,
"Well, there are sort of
"these two reasons that
come from the formalism
"of quantum mechanics
that lead us to expect
"uncertainty with respect to everything,
"including causal properties,
"but maybe also the experimental violation
"of Bell inequalities
tells us also something
"about causality."
But as I note, two thirds of
the way down the page, there,
there may be different
notions of non-classical
causal structure being implied
by these different things.
So keep that in mind.
So here's the theory reason number one.
It's just the Superposition
Principle, right?
We do quantum mechanics in Hilbert space.
And one of the properties
of Hilbert space is
the superposition principle, namely,
if side one is a
solution, a possible state
for some system or a process
that systems can undergo,
and side two is, likewise, a solution,
an event, a process, then any
linear combination of them
is also a solution.
So you've probably heard this described
in the double-slit experiment.
If passage of an electron
or a photon through one slit
is a possible solution, it is,
and passage through the other
slit is a possible solution,
it is, then a superposition
of passage through slit one
and slit two is also a possible solution,
a possible state that
the electron could have,
or the photon, right?
So what this means for
causal processes is that
it's possible that there's a state,
but state here is broader
than state before,
because it characterizes
not an event, but a process,
resulting from two
ordered simple operations.
So you could have a process
where Operation A happens first,
then Operation B happens.
And that process is in a superposition
with the process where B
happens first and then A.
Now, notice I've left
it vague in this setup,
whether there's a causal
relationship between A and B
or whether it's just a
temporal relationship.
And that will make a
difference when we get to
the entanglement harvesting
quantum field theory work
by Henderson and colleagues.
Okay, so prima facie, the
superposition principle
would suggest that superpositions
of processes are possible
in the same way that superpositions
of states are possible.
Theoretical reason number two
is the uncertainty principle,
Heisenberg's uncertainty principle,
that there's a bound on
the precision with which
canonical variables,
commuting variables, rather,
can be simultaneously measured.
The question that many of the physicists
begin their paper with,
who are doing ICO is,
well, if there's uncertainty
regarding property,
classical properties like
position and momentum
and velocity, then it stands
to reason that causality,
which is sort of a meta relation,
a relation that comes out of
the relative space and time
and momentum and velocity
of the systems in question,
then surely there's uncertainty
at that level as well.
And here's my little nota bene,
maybe there's a different kind
of uncertainty that arises
through to causal superpositions,
a superposition of one causal ordering
with a superposition of
another causal ordering
that seems to be a
different state of affairs
than just saying that
there's indefiniteness
or that there's uncertainty
in some causal process.
So, right.
Hi cat, are you weighing in?
Good.
The experimental reason for expecting
indefinite causal ordering
in quantum processes
is just ye old Bell's inequalities, right?
If you have an EPR pair
of entangled particles
and you send them shooting off
in some different directions,
you have spatially separated detectors.
And you measure sort of the
correlation between, I dunno,
polarization of those photons.
And you look at the statistics,
the amount of times
they agree or disagree.
Classical probability
gives you some upper bound
of how often you would
expect them to agree
when you set the detectors to
different angles, and so on.
Bell's inequality says, "Look,
if there's a correlation
"greater than this amount,
then it just can't be described
"by classical processes," right?
So there's already causal
notions packed into
the Bell inequality.
And as many of you are well aware,
interpreting what Bell
tests mean about locality
or separability or
entanglement or causation
has not only spawned new interpretations
of quantum mechanics, but
spawned a robust literature.
So it's a complex question.
But the very rough idea that
Bell's Theorem provides about,
on what a local theory
should be able to describe
versus what a non-local
theory would give rise to,
is sort of considered
by many ICO physicists
to be analogous to what
they're trying to do.
They wanna find bounds that tell them
whether processes are existing in causal
or non-causal orders.
Okay.
So, a little bit of the background, here,
the basic theory of a quantum switch.
And so just, if you don't remember,
quantum cubit is just a
two-state quantum system,
so like a spin half particle or something.
So imagine we got two two-qubit states,
and the two-qubit composite
state capital psi,
where you've got a control Qubit C
and a target Qubit Phi T,
and they live in a joint Hilbert space,
all that's pretty normal
quantum mechanics.
But now we can set up a scenario
where we condition two
different operations,
Operation A, which could just
be a measurement in a lab,
and Operation B, and apply
them to our target state.
So depending on what value
the control state has,
the target state will be
operated on in a different order.
So we might categorize
this down here as bottom,
that if the control
state is at value zero,
or in state zero, or spin up, if you will,
then we're gonna perform
the Operation A first,
then B, on our target qubit.
But if the control qubit
is in, I don't know,
the other states, so spin down, maybe,
then we're gonna perform the operations
in the reverse order on our target qubit.
So we just went through the
superposition principle.
Should be pretty obvious,
that if the control qubit is
able to be in zero or one,
then it follows that it's possible
that it's in a superposition
of zero and one, right?
Maybe a maximally...
A nice superposition right here.
And what results from this is
a superposition of operations.
So you have the process, first A then B,
in a superposition with the
process, first B than A.
And note that this
superposition of processes
is itself a superposition,
but also is itself entangled
with the control qubit state.
So it's non-separable already.
So this is a really
interesting little image,
but I think it's helpful,
is from Rubino et al.
And Rubino and his
colleagues were the first,
as far as I know, to
experimentally directly verify
the existence of
indefinite causal ordering.
And so here, we've got our process matrix
at the bottom, W, who...
I don't have a point...
Can you see my pointer?
Well, don't-
- I think so, Elise.
- [Elise] You can?
- [Priya] Yes.
- All right.
So at the bottom of each
of these three panes,
which are three different scenarios,
we have the process matrix, W,
which tells us what the
path was, what the order was
for the target qubit.
So here's where we're
saying the control qubit is
in state zero, or spin up, if you wish.
In which case the target qubit is...
We'll say that this is Alice.
Alice is in her
independent lab in England,
and she does a measurement
on target qubit,
and then sends it over to Bob.
And Bob is in Istanbul, and
Bob does the measurement,
and he performs process P on it.
And then we get an output, right?
It could go the other direction, as well,
where first Bob gets the target
qubit, and then Alice does.
And then this final state
is the one of interest
for quantum switch, which is
when we have the control qubit
in a superposition of those processes.
In which case, the target
qubit performs a superposition
of both of the prior processes, right?
So it's unclear what
causal ordering is going on
between Alice and Bob.
It's not predetermined by the setup.
Well, I'll say that a little
more about that in a moment.
So another way to characterize this,
in a quantum switch, we've got W.
The particular ordering is it first does
this process A, here.
It first...
Sorry, it goes the other direction.
It first puts the input
state through a superposition
of A and B, and that
gives us some output one,
in parentheses.
Then it sends the input through A then B,
which results in output two.
And then through B then A,
resulting in output three,
and then it coherently
recombines all of those outputs.
And that measurement is the
measurement we're interested in.
It will tell us what degree,
if any, of non-causal ordering
was evident between the
processes: A to B, then B to A.
So in order to make this measurement
or quantify the degree of entanglement
or non-separability
between these causal states
or causal processes, forgive me,
the physicists build a causal witness,
which is an operator that's
supposed to be analogous
to an entanglement witness.
So just in case you don't
know, an entanglement witness
is just a Hermitian operator
that, when it acts on
some composite system, will
give you a density matrix.
When you carry out the trace
of that composite system
with the operator acting on it,
if the trace is less than zero,
you can conclude that the
subsystems are entangled,
and to what degree.
And if the trace is greater
than or equal to zero,
then you conclude that the
composite system was separable.
So analogously, but instead
of using a density matrix,
here we wanna use the process matrix W.
And so here's the difference
between a density matrix
and states with a process
matrix W and processes.
So a causal witness, then, is just
a specially-defined
Hermitian operator that acts
on the process matrix
W, and which describes
the state of the operations.
And again, it yields a
trace of less than zero
if the processes it's witnessing
are causally separable.
So we can say that A
then B happened first,
then B then A happened, or vice versa.
But the measure is greater
than or equal to zero
if they're entangled.
And I believe it is flipped like that,
so it's less than zero
if they're separable
and greater than or equal to
zero if they're entangled.
And so, of course, much like
with the Bell inequalities,
you can come up with
sort of this upper bound,
or with these limitations
for what you expect,
for degrees of entanglement
between these causal processes.
And experimental agreement is high.
So just to back up a little bit,
and maybe put this in
slightly more layman's terms,
I suppose, Rushkoff, and
his colleagues in 2012
sort of gave a theoretical picture of what
this process matrix might be like.
And they assume that there's this game
between Alice and Bob.
I mean, Bob has some
strategy where he's gonna get
his system, he's gonna
receive it from Alice.
And if what he receives from
Alice is a particular state,
then he's gonna do a
particular kind of measurement.
And if it's a different kind of state,
then he'll do a different
kind of measurement.
So his output is conditional
analysis, and so on.
So there's a causal connection
between what Bob does,
the measurement he does,
and what Alice is doing over in her lab.
And so, Rushkoff and his
colleagues calculate that
if you assume that there's a causal order,
that it's very clear that
Alice sends her states to
Bob, he does his measurements,
and he's successful,
conditional on the input
of Alice's lab, they say
that the success will be
less than three fourths of the time
he's gonna be able to implement a strategy
that is successful, okay?
However, if they set up this...
Again, it's like a superposition
of the causal ordering
in the quantum switch, right?
If Alice and Bob, the
order that they receive
each other's information or states
is not determined beforehand,
so it's not that Alice
sends results to Bob
and Bob makes a conditional decision,
if it's indeterminate, then, in fact,
Bob's rate of success at
adjusting his measurement
based on what he received as
input from Alice is higher.
This is exciting because, at
least for Rushkoff and others,
it shows that, perhaps, if you do have
a indefinite causal ordering
between these two operations,
you can get a higher efficiency.
You can get a success rate
for certain computations
that's higher than if you're dealing with
causally-ordered sets of operations.
And that was, in fact, what was proven
in Procopio et al, 2013.
So they indirectly verified
the indefinite causal ordering
of a quantum switch.
So they didn't use a causal witness.
So they didn't get an exact
measure on the entanglement.
But what they did was they showed that
they could get higher
efficiency on some computation
when using a quantum circuit that was in
a causal superposition,
as opposed to a circuit
that was causally
ordered in its processes.
So the teams listed below said,
"Okay, well, we wanna do one better.
"We want to implement
this causal witness schema
"and see if we can directly verify
"indefinite causal ordering."
Because in a sense, what
Procopia et al had done
is just to show that the
superposition was more effective
than sort of separable causal ordering.
But Rubin et al and Boswami et al
wanted to get quantitative about it.
So they developed the causal witness.
And they did in fact measure values
that were in close agreement with
the theoretical expectation for
non-separable causal processes.
So upshot here, these direct verifications
of indefinite causal ordering are showing
our measurements of
entangled causal processes,
of processes where order
A and B is entangled
with B and A, and so on.
Pretty bizarre. (laughs)
I would like to talk briefly about
what might be happening
in quantum field theory.
And as far as I'm aware,
a lot of this work
stems from something Brookner
said in a 2014 paper,
which is sort of a review of the field
physics and causality right now.
And so, he made this
interesting suggestion
after describing the
quantum switch, saying,
"Well, look, we could probably
do something analogous
"using a massive object
that's in a superposition
"of positions."
Because if they're spatially separated,
the component states have
some spatial separation
that they're entangled over,
that means that the gravitational field
that that massive object produces
will also be in a superposition of states.
Ergo, the space-time geometry itself
will be in a superposition.
And so, I have this quote
from him here, that,
"The causal succession of gate operations
"in a quantum circuit," or quantum switch,
"is the analog of events
separated by a time-like interval.
"This analogy can be pushed further.
"The networks in which
geometry of the wires
"between the gates is entangled with
"the state of the control qubit,"
so again, the quantum switch situation,
"Can be thought of as a toy model
"for the quantum gravity situation,"
that he introduced before.
Namely, "If you put a massive object
"in a spatial superposition,
"then the metric that's produced,
"hence spatiotemporal
distances between the events
"in the gravitational field get entangled
"with the object's position."
So this suggests new ways
to understand entanglement
at different locations in a field,
and also to possibly motivate or constrain
the ways we quantize general relativity.
So to that end, very recently,
here's the Henderson et al
paper that I mentioned earlier,
"Quantum Temporal
Superposition: The Case of QFT."
I'm gonna be really brief on this
because I wanna get to the philosophy.
Quantum field theories
describe correlations
between space-time points.
That's what they do.
So if we put a really tiny little,
like a quantum system
that's a particle detector
in the field and we
couple it to the field,
then it can perform
measurements on the field
and can tell us about local values.
It can tell us about
correlations, and so on.
So these physicists asked the question,
and you notice Brookner is
among the colleagues here.
So maybe he made that 2014 suggestion
with malice aforethought.
But question, what if we
put two particle detectors
out in the field that are
in a quantum superposition
and then use that composite
or superposed detectors,
use it to probe field correlations?
Another way to say that is, in particular,
to harvest entanglement, to
measure degrees of correlation,
quantum correlation, in the field.
Will we, in analogy with a quantum switch,
find higher efficacy
when the detectors are
in superposed states?
Will they be able to measure
a higher degree of...
More effectively measure
entanglement, rather?
And it looks like that
is, in fact, the case.
So they looked at two
different situations here.
So they took...
So on the left-hand side, here,
they have the two different detectors
that are in a cause-effect superposition.
So it's an explicit superposition
where A will cause some
later state in detector B,
and B causes A, right?
Whereas on the right side,
it's just the past future.
So it's just a temporal
ordering, A before B,
that is the time that the
detector takes a measurement.
A before B and then B before A.
They found some weird...
First of all, that they could
propose this theoretically
is quite something, because
there are no-go theorems
about how the signaling among
the superimposed detectors
can work, and so on.
It was quite a feat.
But it's interesting
because they found out that
in each, in the left-hand case
and in the right-hand case
in this image, you have different branches
of the superposition.
And while you can transform one branch,
either from a cause-effect
superposition to...
Sorry, from a cause-effect
situation to a past-future,
you cannot ever do that so
that both branches agree
in cause-effect, whether
they're cause-effect relations
or past-future relations.
So there's sort of that interesting way
that it looks like they're able to tell,
by coupling these detectors in
the right way with the field,
and they're being in
superposition with one another,
they can differentiate
between superpositions
that are just A before B and B before A,
versus legitimate
superpositions of A causes B,
with B causes A.
So one of my worries earlier on was that,
well, just because they're
indefinitely causal
or causally ordered, or even in a...
Is not necessarily the same thing as being
in a superposition of A causes B
just as much as B causes A, if you will.
But this proposed
experiment does seem to be
able to discriminate
between what I might call
a genuine superposition
of causal processes.
And that's truly weird.
On the efficacy front, they do find that
putting detectors in superpositions
in this way allows them
to be more effective,
to more effectively perform
entanglement harvesting.
So just as with the quantum circuit,
it was found that a
superposition of causal states
was more effective for
a certain computation,
here they're finding that
entanglement harvesting,
or just the probing of the field
for different correlations,
is more effective when you're dealing with
superposition of detectors, as opposed to
pure states of detectors.
Okay, that's the physics,
it's all pretty brand-spanking new.
What can we say about it?
Here are some things I was thinking about.
If we think about the proposal made by
some of the physicists,
that causality might be
just another aspect of
the uncertainty relations,
it's uncertain because causality
is ultimately redefined
in terms of variables at the lower level
and those variables are
susceptible to uncertainty
because of quantum mechanics, right?
Okay, maybe.
But that doesn't seem to
be what the quantum switch
or the superpositions
of particle detectors
in a quantum field are seeing.
It's not that they're seeing uncertainty
in the ordering of processes
it's that they're measuring superpositions
of well-defined causal processes.
So I'm not sure that
what benefit it might be
to think about causality as analogous
to uncertain properties
like position, momentum,
velocity, and so on.
A further problem is
that the interpretation
of the uncertainty relations
is somewhat debatable.
I mean, there are limits
on whether you can assign
well-defined values to a
system before measurements.
And those limits are
described by, for instance,
the Kockin Specker Theorem.
But there are ways that you might recover
a sort of epistemic or
operational understanding
of uncertainty, where
it has to do not with
the nature of the world itself.
The world itself is just
defined perfectly clearly,
all the states are
definite states, and so on,
and it's just that by doing measurements
on a quantum system introduce disturbances
of a kind that lead to uncertainty
in various properties of the system.
But I'm wondering if there's room to make
sort of a more metaphysical
or ontological claim here,
that if you do understand
the uncertainty relations,
that's saying something
about the way the world is,
and not just how we measure the world.
Or if you understand the
way we measure the world
to be a part of the way the world is,
maybe measurement just
is defined as weekly as
an interaction, any sort of interaction.
Interactions are happening all
the time, all over the place.
What is the nature of those interactions?
I'm not sure how we would ever determine
whether ICO makes
legitimate an interpretation
of causality as fuzzy, or
is uncertain in this way.
But I wanna think more about it.
What seems more plausible and, in fact,
quantitatively plausible, as well,
is that we might be able
to come up with theorems
for measuring or gauging the quantumness
of relationships between systems.
And quantum correlations, I
tend to read as entanglement.
I think that's what's meant
by quantum correlations,
entanglement.
So in this way, we can use
these bounds on causality
to understand more about
entanglement relations
among different kinds of systems,
just in the same way that we've measured
spacial entanglement using Bell tests,
or maybe the way that we
look at temporal correlations
and gauge the quantumness
of a system through time
using Leggett-Garg inequalities.
So it's been proposed
by, I think Brookner was
one of these physicists,
that it looks like causality
that a process, and not just
the spatial-temporal location
of events, but that a series of events,
might also have bounds that describe
entanglement thresholds, as it were.
There is a further question
which I want to explore,
which is whether causality is recoverable
in causally-neutral formulations of QM.
So these causally-neutral
formulations do exist.
They're out there.
But whether they're
realizable in some way,
and whether the kind of causality,
the notion of causality that
is recoverable from them is...
Well, what kind is it?
Is it merely a descriptive
kind of causality?
Is it a loose ordering of events
where you have certain probability bounds,
like conditional probabilities
that, given this event,
the probability that
this other event happened
prior to it as such and such?
Okay, whether those are
the kinds of causal notions
that emerge from
causally-neutral formulations
of quantum theory, or whether it is
some robust sense of
causality that there's really,
as Norton would put it,
sort of a factual constraint
that's being imposed upon
the systems we're measuring
that is causal in nature,
yet doesn't exist at the very bottom level
where we have indefinite causal ordering.
And then the last sort of
physics-y speculative point,
which I won't go into, is
just as Bell's inequalities
and perhaps Leggett-Garg inequalities,
but to a lesser extent, but
certainly Bell's inequalities
carved up the interpretation space
for non-relativistic quantum mechanics
in a very different sort of way, right?
It made more clear the
goal of a de Broglie-Bohm
contextual hidden variables theory.
This is what the theory
needed to do to recover
empirical data, yet account for causality
because de Broglie-Bohm, they want to have
sort of classical processes
in the background,
or recover classical
processes the level of,
I don't know, the universe, maybe.
Right, so maybe in the same way,
if we come up with causality inequalities
based on indefinite causal ordering,
that will shed some
light on or re-carve up
the interpretation space
in an interesting way.
But I suspect that the right move is not
to re-carve up the space, but in fact...
Oh, this is a general conclusion,
but I'll go to it now.
No, I won't. (laughs)
Hold on, just keep it in mind.
I suspect that it's just more impetus
for ditching causality
as a fundamental aspect
of our interpretation of the
world in the first place.
So if you've built, as some
Bohmians, for instance,
and sorry I'm picking on
Bohmians today, most days,
if the Bohmians have...
Their motivation for developing
their pilot wave theory
or their potential hidden variables theory
was to recover, at the macro
scale, classical behavior,
they want their systems tracing out
quasi-neutronean trajectories,
they want the world particle
to be moving deterministically,
that means that the prior state is a cause
for the later state, and so on.
So a large motivation for
that interpretation is
to recover classical notions,
among them causality,
arguably, in which case,
maybe this is just another reason
to sort of avoid that interpretation.
Okay.
Another point to make very quickly is that
a lot of discussion about
relativistic causality in physics,
and, as far as I know, in
the philosophical literature
has focused on signaling and
the bounds placed on signaling
by no-signaling theorems and so on.
But I think that these ICO processes
and the Henderson et al
detectors and superpositions
in the field, I think these
are methods of understanding
or of approaching the question
of relativistic causality
that are not primarily about signaling.
So it might be just different
avenue for thinking about
relativistic causality, broadly speaking.
How are we on time?
Oh, fantastic.
I shall now wrap up.
I've already mentioned
some of the relativistic consequences,
namely that it gives us more
specific details about...
It gives us larger regions
for entanglement harvesting.
So we just learn more
about the quantum field
when we couple it to superposed
detectors in this way.
But we also asked the question,
and I heard Henderson at a talk she gave,
she ended the talk by saying,
"It looks like we're dealing with
"physically-superposed detectors that have
"a real effect on the
probing of entanglement."
What does this mean?
What does this mean for how we construct
future quantized theories?
I think she was asking, "What
is the metaphysics of this?"
Right?
Well, let's figure it out.
I've mentioned, also,
that it motivates attempts
to develop a theory of quantum gravity
or any kind of quantum theory
that is background independent.
So it doesn't assume going
in that there's a set
space-time manifold, or that
there's causal structure
embedded in the background, okay?
So maybe...
Ooh, that was supposed to...
I didn't finish editing that point.
But go on to three, look down at three,
don't pay attention to two. (laughs)
Oreshkov and others have suggested that
if causality, like space-time,
should be considered
dynamically emergent, I mean,
what we see at the macro scale
as clear causal connections,
do not exist in that definite
way at the micro level,
then perhaps we can
start building up a story
about the emergence of those more concrete
or more classical causal structures.
And maybe, I suggest,
those are dynamical stories
that involve, for instance,
quantum decoherence processes,
which can effectively
damp those superpositions
so that even though they are
physically superpositions,
they nevertheless are only measurable
by some other probe, by
an environment, by us,
by a lab, by Alice, by Bob
as being effectively
an Eigen state, right?
So not in a superposition.
And it might even support
canonical approaches
to quantum gravity over
co-variant approaches
because canonical approaches,
because the Willard equation
doesn't evolve in time,
time has to come from somewhere.
And there's some work, like Moravia et al
has this interesting paper where
he and his team derive,
say that even if you have
a static macro system or composite system,
if you carve it up into subsystems
that are entangled with each
other in the right sort of way,
they can be evolving in time
and you still have a composite
state that is static.
Well, that's exactly the
sort of thing you want
for a canonical approach
to quantum gravity,
where the real equation
is not evolving in time.
But again, it's possible that
a project like Moravia's,
that has to do with recovering
time from entanglement,
is possible in terms of causal processes
as emergent from entanglement in that way.
Okay, so the specific thesis, just,
it seems that this physics,
just the fact that there
are a lot of people studying
indefinite causal processes
in a variety of ways,
and not just operationally,
but as what it could tell us
about fundamental features of the world
like entanglement in quantum field theory,
that causality either just
isn't a part of the world
at the lower level, or if
it is, it's indefinite,
but we should become clear about
in what sense it's indefinite
and if there are bounds
on how definite it is
or indefinite it is.
And given that we do use
cause at higher levels,
what is the nature of
these causal processes,
given that there's clear evidence that
if they are emergent,
which they probably are,
how does that emergence
process happen, right?
There's nothing causal
at the fundamental level,
whence cause at this higher level.
Right.
And then, of course, looking
at the relativistic case
of Henderson et al, we can understand more
about entanglements in
relativistic scenarios
by studying using indefinite
causal ordering as a tool
to probe so it's not
just that we've measured
indefinite causal ordering,
it's that we're now using
indefinite causal ordering
to understand other parts
of the physical universe.
That's pretty cool.
Ending where I began.
If we look at the three major camps
for metaphysics of causation,
it looks like causal fundamentalists have
an even harder task, given ICO.
So for instance, the
Bohmians often say that
we require a primitive
ontology that has a law,
that's a causal law, and
the Bohemian world particle
evolves according to that causal law.
That seems less attractive
to me, given ICO,
and sort of all this active research.
And the eliminativists,
there could be serious problems, too,
because if causal talk, like Norton wants,
is only allowed in virtue of
its being ultimately reduceable
to some non-causal micro theory,
well, what if it's not
just there's no cause
down there in this...
Or that it...
But that it's sort of
entangled causal processes.
There have been arguments already
in the non-relativistic
literature that you can't have
reduction onto a base that's entangled
because entanglement is sort
of a holistic property, right?
Entanglement relations
cannot be further reduced
because the parts are something
different than the whole.
Hello, hello.
And then finally, I think
this comes out on top
for the non-fundamentalists.
They seem to be safe on their claim
that causality does not exist
in the fundamental makeup of the universe,
but it seems like we still have
important uses for
recovering causal processes
or causal models, like
the quantum Markovian
causal processes at the higher level.
Quantum Markovian models, rather.
But I think the task may
have become slightly harder,
given ICO, because
there's maybe a larger gap
between the fundamental
level and where it is
that causality comes in and is useful
to our modeling processes.
Okay, so a lot.
Very speculative.
Can't wait to have a discussion with you.
Here are very brief references.
Thank you very much. (laughs)
- I thank you so much, Elise,
for this wonderful talk.
Much to think about.
And before I open up
the floor for questions,
I wanted to acknowledge the fact that
we are delighted, Elise, that
you are part of our core team
for this project.
So excited to have you
part of the organizing team
to help us understand.
And I also want to give a shout out.
In the audience, we have Lorenzo Maniani,
who was one of our previous speakers,
who has dialed in from Italy.
And we have the person
who I consider my guru
in quantum mechanics,
whose book I learned from,
Ramamurthy Shankar is in the audience.
And we also have Peter
Morgan, who is thinking about
these issues, who is in the audience,
as well as Chris Mink.
So yeah, you've drawn quite
the crowd, Professor Crull.
(laughs) So I think...
And I also have greetings
from Canada for you.
So, you've had fans across the globe.
So I think I want to
start with one question
that one of our, again,
a regular attendee,
Sanjeev Kumar, has, and it's
really a question he has
about classification.
So in the consciousness-only ontology,
the non-causal substrate of consciousness
becomes compatible with
temporal causation.
I feel not sure how that is,
but that's a big claim, right?
Does your framework tie with
the consciousness-only ontology?
You knew this was coming, right?
A question about the big-
- [Elise] On consciousness?
- Yes. (laughs)
- Well, I'm about to shock you all.
Hang on to your chairs.
(Priya laughing)
I'm not...
I don't...
Hmm.
I take it that the
consciousness-only view,
which I'm not super familiar with,
but it's still a physicalist view, yes?
- [Priya] Yes.
- I'm not a physicalist.
So I really can't answer that question,
because for me, consciousness will not be
ultimately describable in physical terms.
And so, whether or not the
physics that we do have
can adequately recover
temporal-spatial causal notions
is a very different question for me.
Yeah, so that's a very short answer
to a very complex question, but...
Right.
I think, in fact, if there's anything
that can be said here at all, it's that
causations being less likely
to sit at the fundamental level
could be used in various ways by folks
arguing for consciousness
from quantum systems, right?
It depends on your end game.
If causality is supposed to be a feature
of our Noetic structure,
then the fact that
it's not at the quantum level is maybe
not so much of a problem.
But if all there is is consciousness,
but there isn't causality
at that fundamental level,
then you're gonna have to
do maybe a lot more legwork
to sort of explain whence sort
of this conscious awareness
of causality that seems so natural to us
in all the sciences and
not just in physics.
But yeah, I'm really out of my depth
talking about consciousness
to physicalists.
So... (laughs)
- So I guess I have something
that has sort of confused me.
One of the many things that
is complex and confusing.
So are you making a distinction
between entanglement
being an intrinsic property
versus an emergent property?
Or am I really confusing by saying that
you cannot reduce it?
Is that what you're saying?
- So I'm thinking not in a temporal sense,
but in the metaphysics
sense that you might,
if you want to give a totally...
If you wanna reduce the
whole world to bits and bops
that are quanta, but these quanta exist
in entanglement relations, that means that
my quantum system over here,
its properties are not fully described
by the spatial-temporal region I carve out
that contains, I don't know,
even the majority of the mass.
Of that object, right?
If it's entangled, it may have properties
that are spatially-temporally extended.
- [Priya] Right, right.
- That's all I meant by that.
So it's not really that-
- Sort of the non-local nature, I see.
- Yes, yeah, yeah.
So it has to do with
non-local, absolutely, yep.
- Any other questions?
Yemima, if you feel free to
ask questions today, as well,
we would really greatly
benefit by anyone now
asking thoughtful questions to clarify.
- [Shankar] Priya, can I jump in, here?
- Yes, yes, Shankar, please do.
- [Shankar] So I think the
subject is very difficult,
but I do feel that if somebody
could explain it to me,
it is our speaker today.
- Oh wow.
- 'Cause the part
that I knew, I could see
how well it was explained,
but lots of it I don't know,
I'm just a Copenhagen hack.
I sort of know
(Priya laughing)
the standard way to do it.
In my world, measuring
instruments that are
for different size from
the measured objects,
and a very clear distinction between
the macroscopic world needed
to define measurements.
I think, in this study,
you're reaching a domain
where they get blurred,
where they get small.
So their issues are never talked about.
But as I said, if I want to
learn what those issues are,
this was a very good introduction.
So I gotta thank her,
Elise, for doing that.
- I'm really honored.
Can I ask you a question
while I've got you?
- Yes, I was just gonna say.
- As a philosopher of physics,
it may not be the one you
want, but as a philosopher,
I'm a student of John Howard's,
who was famous, among other things,
for writing about the myth of
the Copenhagen interpretation,
sort of historically.
It was an interpretation
Heisenberg came up with
after World War II that
aligned more closely with Bohr.
Bohr emerged from World War II as a hero,
advocating Glasnost, then
meeting with Churchill.
And well, he did work on
the Manhattan Project,
but he was, I don't
know, careful about it.
He was very conscientious.
Heisenberg did not
emerge from World War II
with a similar reputation.
And so, it was...
He made it up, okay?
So if you historically
study Heisenberg's view
and Paolie's view and Yordan's view
and Einstein's view and Schrodinger's view
in the period 1926 to 1935,
which I have a book coming out on that.
They have very rich and very
nuanced different views.
So here's my question.
Many physicists-assigned
counters still claim
to be Copenhagen people, but they're...
What does Copenhagen mean for you?
That there's a distinct classical realm?
Or that measurement processes produce
truly definite outcomes,
not just apparently or
effectively definite outcomes?
- [Shankar] Yeah, I imagine a world.
Look, you got experiments
going on all the time.
In CERN, they're measuring particles.
There's a probability distribution
for where the particle will land.
- Right.
- [Shankar] And if it
detected a place or an angle
and you vary the angle, there's
a function that's predicted.
And that seems to work.
We seem to know what we mean
when we measure the pion
in this detector.
That's the level at which I
understand quantum mechanics,
the level at which it works.
- Okay.
- [Shankar] But there, detectors
that you would, in fact,
particular experimentalist
never fail to show you
how big they are compared
to a human being.
All the pictures have it.
You would detect it in a tiny
person standing next to them.
That world, the problems
you say will not arise.
You can never put two of those big guys
in a superposed state.
- Right.
- [Shankar] So I don't have
the issues you are raising.
These are issues.
You have to deal with the
issues before they come
and ruin your life.
But at the moment, I'm almost
finished with my career,
so I'm not worried about what'll
happen 15 years from now,
but these could be dominant issues.
- Yeah, and so, I mean, this
is brand new stuff for me.
What I have mostly done,
aside from the historical
and foundational work
is decoherence studies,
and looked at sort of that.
And so, it does seem clear
that, at least in principle,
there is no well-defined domain.
I mean, even if you take
the usual limiting theorems,
like Aaron Fest's theorum
or the Louisville regime
or whatever, none of these
gives a universal description
or a universal classification
that slices the world
where you get just classical
systems on one side
and quantum on the other,
whatever those may be.
You always have problems.
And so let's just let
everything be quantum (laughs)
and then let the dynamics
of quantum processes,
like decoherence-
- [Shankar] That's true.
- Tell us why we see
effectively classical states
at mezzoscopic and macroscopic scales.
- [Shankar] Right.
And there are also people
at Yale, like Jack Harris,
who are flirting with the dividing line
between classical and quantum.
They got mechanical objects, which are,
I think, the largest one in
which you can see superposition.
So they are cantilibra oscillators,
which can be in a superposed state.
- Right.
- [Shankar] It's a big enough thing that
you could probably see in a microscope,
but yet it is really
in a superposed state.
But I thought everyone agrees
that that is challenging,
but it's gonna be a long way from getting
anything substantial
in a superposed state.
- And that's partly the game too, right?
Because this is clearly a
problem for quantum computing,
where you want to shield your...
You want to maintain the
integrity of your qubits.
You can only do that by
maintaining coherence.
But decoherence is so damn
defective and so fast,
that this is a real engineering problem.
But if we're concerned with,
if we're interested in the metaphysics,
the fact that we're
trying to shield systems
from losing this property indicates
something about the way
nature prefers it, as it were,
in sort of this quantum
entangled situation.
Yeah.
- [Shankar] Yes, I agree.
I think I shouldn't monopolize your time,
so thanks for taking my comment
and maybe I should let
other people talk to you.
- [Priya] Thanks, Shankar.
- [Shankar] Okay, I'm
going to mute myself.
- Yeah, so there, I think,
Peter, did you have a question
or did you just wanna give that shout out?
I guess-
- Just a shout out. (laughs)
- [Yemima] I think.
Do you want me to ask them?
- Just a shout out, yeah.
Yemima, please go ahead, yeah.
- Yeah, so just to...
First of all, thanks,
fascinating description
of all these new developments.
And we can talk about the metaphysics,
so what is causation tomorrow?
But I was just thinking
about backwards causation
or retro-causation, and
you could understand
what you described, or
certainly entanglements.
There were ideas about
expanding entanglement,
in terms of retro causality.
You never mentioned the term,
but what you said seems
to be compatible with that
in some cases.
So what is the connection
between what you said and
what those interpreters
of quantum mechanics,
like say retro-causation,
as an explanation?
- Well, Yemima, thanks.
I hope that's something we can talk about
at more length tomorrow,
and I sort of intentionally
left it out today.
I waved at it from a
distance when I talked about
the different, like maybe
that there's some...
There's the lack of clarity about
whether we're talking
about causal processes
that are causally ordered,
and it's just unclear.
Of course-
- Right.
- A superposition of a
legitimate A cause B,
but then B cause A, and
retro causality would only
really apply to part of
one of those situations.
And so, in a sense, if we can sort out
what a superposition of
causal processes really means,
that will illuminate how
much overlap, if any,
there is with the retro-causal literature.
But retro-causality...
So one of the historical figures
I've done a lot of work
on is Gretta Herrmann,
who wrote the greatest and maybe the first
philosophic treatise on
quantum mechanics, in 1935.
And she she's a Kantean,
so she wants to preserve a
fundamental causal principle.
But she does this by first teasing apart,
as you well know, Yemima,
as you do so nicely in the
introduction to your book,
determination and prediction
is a separate thing,
and the existence of a
chain of cause and effect.
And there is a chain of cause and effect,
she says, in quantum mechanics,
we just cannot know it beforehand.
We can know it retrodictively.
So it's not retrocausality,
but sort of retrodiction of something
that already existed in the world,
is sort of her way of maintaining
the causal completeness
of quantum mechanics.
But yeah, I know Hugh
Price and others have done
really interesting work
on perpetual causality.
And if a retrocausal
thesis is still required,
a particular causal ordering of events,
it's just not in the order
we are used to or experience.
That's a different thing than saying
that it's a one of square
root two superposition
of A caused B and B caused A.
What does that mean?
So I hope we can talk
about that more tomorrow,
and you can teach me some things
about retrocausality. (laughs)
- Oh, great.
So I just wanted to read
out a couple of shout-outs
before moving on to the next question.
So Lorenzo Moniani said...
Has provided a reference on some ideas
about physics of consciousness.
He refers to the area of studies called
the so-called dissipative brain.
For example, there's
a chapter in a volume,
"Understanding Brain and Consciousness"
by Zvitlelo Vitelo.
And he's given the reference
for anyone who wants it,
in the chat.
And Peter Morgan gave a
shout out for Dawn Howard's
2004 paper pointing out
the difference between
Bohr and Heisenberg on the nature of...
That's a wonderful paper.
And he's mentioning that
it was formative for him.
It was quite the paper to plow
through, but it's excellent.
So I think, for those...
It was another of our regular attendees,
and fellow astrophysicist,
he has a very nice question,
which is sort of where
I was going next, too,
that he says, "You mentioned decoherence
"and that your thesis
work was based on it.
"Can you elaborate a little bit more
"on how this may have influenced
your developing the ideas,
"for example, that
you've presented today?"
- Sure, well... (laughs)
Decoherence is due to entanglement.
So there's a deep
mother-daughter relationship
between entanglement and decoherence.
And there's also a lot of
philosophical interests,
but also confusion about
both of these properties.
Well, excuse me,
entanglement as a property
that systems might have and degrees of it
and as it evolves through time,
and decoherence as a temporal...
As a dynamical process.
So I've been thinking for a
long time about entanglements
in that guise, how it gives rise to
and how it's not evidence at
the mezzo and macro scale,
because of...
A lot of puzzles having
to do with entanglement,
I think can be given
explanations via decoherence.
So that's the relationship
between entitlement
and decoherence.
But also, of course, these
questions have to do with
the quantum to classical transition.
And because I'm interested
in talking to metaphysicists,
metaphysicians.
I think they go by metaphysicians,
but it ought to be metaphysicists.
I'm interested in understanding ontology,
but in a way where it captures
our best physics, right?
And our best physics says that
there's no hard and fast way
to carve up the universe
into classical and quantum
or even individual or
closed or isolated systems.
You were talking about dissipation.
Well, dissipation is a big problem, right?
The fact that we can effectively
deal with Eigen states
or that we effectively
measure with pointers
a particular value for
our measurement outcome,
that there is a quantum process underlying
those classical phenomenon
was really something
I wanted to understand.
Now, causality is a little bit higher up
because it's sort of leaping a step,
because I wanna think a little bit...
Entanglement as a process
across space and time.
And if you think about it,
because we're in a 4D
or more world, right?
So when we talk about
entanglement relations,
even when we call it the
measuring of special correlations
in a Bell type experiment,
we're in fact already
doing causal entanglement
because those detectors are
at space-time locations.
And so just getting clear about...
I started to ask about the
Leggett-Garg inequalities
and what they really have to
say about temporal correlations
and how we define macro versus micro
versus mezzo systems and so on.
And from special correlations
and temporal collations came causality.
And then, also, Priya asked me
to give a talk on causality.
So... (laughs)
that's a long-winded answer
to your question, but yeah.
So I'm new to the causality
and this is one of the reasons
I'm extraordinarily honored
and excited to have
Yemima have conversation
with us tomorrow, because
she is an expert on causation
and science and in physics, and will bring
a lot more fruit from what
I've said, I hope. (laughs)
- Yeah, and I think that...
Thank you so much, because
I think that thing that
is confusing to a lot of us
is this idea of determinism,
causation, transparency of
causes, chains of causation.
All these things are
really hard to kind of
clearly parse out when we
are trying to understand.
You look at a model and
you're trying to figure out
a chain of causation and
what all you can infer
from a model, given the
priors that have gone into
constructing the model
to start with, right?
So, yeah.
That was...
Really looking forward to it.
Are there any other
questions from the floor?
Let me just take a look at the chat
to see if anything else has...
- [Elise] I don't think anything
else has come in, Priya.
- Okay, great.
So I think at this point,
we should just then wrap up
with looking forward to tomorrow's
really wonderful discussion
where we can learn more.
Thank you, Elise, so much for
a really, really nice talk.
And I mean, I'm sort of
tempted to ask a question,
which I will pose to both of you tomorrow,
which is, what do you really
make of the prospects,
the claim prospects for quantum computing?
And whether...
Are we being extremely optimistic
or is that just a completely
different functional realm?
If you can get it to
work, you get it to work.
It doesn't matter if we don't understand
how it works, right?
So, I guess we'll get to that tomorrow.
Thank you everyone for attending.
And I want to say a big
thanks to Ty, once again,
for helping with managing and arranging
this entire series and this talk.
And I want to thank Ryan for helping us
with the recording and making
the talks available online.
So thank you, everyone.
Have a lovely evening, and
see you all tomorrow afternoon
at the same time, so 3:00 PM EST.
Bye.
- [Elise] Thank you.